a and spay were frozen in it do you
wanna build a snowman what is this
frozen game wow this is so weird
we should lay so hard my mine too
wow they're frozen actually Anna and
ever out in the snow oh do you want to
build a snowman with me when Robocop
come on let's go and play let's go and
play I never see you anymore come out
the door it's live go away I'm coming
back oh no there's Teletubbies what did
you do oh god there's so many
Teletubbies it's Lady gaga
damn it ah Lady Gaga's got my face he's
riding Yemen Lady Gaga to write me
conceal don't feel don't let them know
but now they know Robocop is healing me
Robocop thanks a Real American Hero
come on Ken come on let's build a
snowman oh yeah come on so happy
come on Oh knock knock knock come on
adore the Snowman come on let's go and
play
wait a bit of Sandman just coming and
one of the snow it went a bit you might
have been come on yeah she's coming up
in the same spin spin ah spill it away
come on just come Traverse Dora we're
gonna be the salmon come on oh god no do
you want it let me go let me go oh my
god
oh god oh god oh I just wanted to know
that he whatever Feliz snowman what have
you done it's time for else that you
like to tell it I wish go why I know
what to build a snowman but but [ __ ] you
in your snowman good memories you got
something on your face dude what you
wanna build a snowman
oh my god Anna listen to you're finally
taking me to to Taylor Swift concert
sorry I got a I got a powder my nose
it's pretty frozen oh why are you going
in the boys bathroom cuz I have a dick
oh oh my God we're here oh my gosh what
else
Taylor will over here she wouldn't let
us down oh look there's Taylor oh man
she's pretty oh my god I got Taylor's
music wow people say people say we're
ready
Teletubbies - Taylor Swift this is the
best game ever all the Bears gonna say
played a fake haters gonna bake a cake
hey Kay wait there's a Taylor Swift book
here was that here I shoot it wow this
Jane
just with PSV we're coming tailored a
bag and then and a hurry to the VIP I
get all the celebrities waiting for you
know the folks back and I don't make me
leave without you yeah afternoon to go
he's going to put a stop it
yeah it's plain this is [ __ ] amazing
oh my memory of Anna at least I have the
Hulk makes everything seems mud to
seaward I don't you attach to let it go
this is the weirdest video ever I had to
let you go again